So this is absolute and total gold we've been
talking about, how will Republicans defend
or not defend radical Congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor Green's various comments, including
about a Jewish space laser starting wildfires
when she harassed teen activist David Hogge
on the streets of Washington, D.C., when she
encouraged violence and even posted to Facebook
about the murder of Democrats, denying 9/11,
denying Sandy Hook and so on and so forth.
And so far, we saw on yesterday's show, we
saw Republican Congressman Steve Scalise turn
the question into an answer about Joe Biden,
China and carbon.
So that's one approach, which is just don't
even answer the question.
Answer about something else.
Attack Joe Biden.
We saw on yesterday's show Republican Congresswoman
Nancy Mace did do a both sides thing, which
was to say, OK, well, both sides have crazy
people in them.
So that's sort of like a what about ism?
Both sides type response.
Trump Brownnoser and Republican Senator Lindsey
Graham is taking a third approach, which is
to say that the comments might have been taken
out of context.
He barely seems able to even get the names
right of the various conspiracies touted by
Marjorie Taylor Green.
But he says, what about context?
To take a look at this, that you have spent
some time with her.
Where do you come down on this idea of whether
she should be stripped of committee assignments
or rather me talking about what she may have
said?
I want to hear from her.
So I flew down to Georgia with her on Air
Force One, had a very pleasant experience
with her, a very, very cordial, very pleasant.
So here's what I think she owes herself, quite
frankly, her constituents in the country.
Is that true?
Was she misquoted?
Was she taken out of context?
I want to know, does she still believe that
Sandy Hook's was faked, that 911 was an inside
job, that there's a Jewish laser laser in
the sky starting fires in California?
I don't know.
I know how words can be twisted.
I know how you can be taken out of context.
But rather than me talking about her, I would
like her to be definitive.
I seriously love that.
Does she really think a Jewish space laser
or laser, as Lindsay says, is starting wildfires?
Because, you know, her comments about a Jewish
space laser might lack some context within
which they'd be reasonable comments to make.
We need the full context of when she talked
about a Jewish space laser.
What can you imagine that being the defense,
the only context that would be relevant about
what Marjorie Taylor Greene said about a Jewish
space laser would be if she had said what
I am about to say is a joke right before saying
it assured of that.
What sort of context would make a comment
like that about Jewish space lasers even remotely
reasonable?
And in terms of context, much of this stuff
was on a post on Facebook.
That's the context.
The Post is the context.
And this is just another form of Republican
gaslighting now that I think of some other
examples.
Is there a context that makes the statement
the moon landing was faked reasonable?
I guess the context would be I'm about to
say something that's a joke.
Like I can't think of another context that
would make the statement the moon landing
was faked.
Reasonable vaccines cause autism might be
a totally reasonable thing if we had the context
only.
Yeah, but the only context would be I'm about
to say something that is untrue.
Maybe when she stalked teen activist David
Hogg and it was caught on video, maybe there
was missing context there as well.
I don't know.
And while we're at it, maybe there's context
that makes Lindsey Graham's comment less ridiculous,
although I can't really think of what it would
be.
Now, here's a serious question.
Is it possible?
That Republicans like Lindsay and others don't
know what context means, so when they say
this was taken out of context, they actually
don't understand the meaning of that.
Is that a possibility?
I mean, we've had a lot of times where we'll
be engaged in a week long or month long discussion
with the discussion, maybe is a bit of a favorable
term, but a disagreement with the right about
something.
And after two months, you'll realize, oh,
my goodness, they don't even know what this
word means.
We're arguing about something, assuming both
sides understand the meaning of the words
we're using.
And this entire time they're using a word
that they don't even understand or they misunderstand.
Maybe Lindsey Graham doesn't know what context
means, but in any case, it's sort of like
a pick your own adventure.
Either Marjorie Taylor Greene misspoke or
it was posted by a staffer, not really Marjorie
Taylor Greene, or maybe the video was deep
faked or maybe it was taken out of context
or she was telling a joke or she was on a
medication at that point in time.
Like just pick one.
Whichever one makes you feel better about
what she said, pick your own adventure and
go with it.
And so far, three different responses to Marjorie
Taylor Green's comments.
Let's now talk about the fourth response.